Figaro live 16h02 bonjour bienvenue
plongeons ensemble cet après-midi dans
le monde fascinant et inquiétant des
sectes une en particulier connu tout
particulièrement grâce ou à cause de son
célèbre gourou Claude vorillon dit Raël
évidemment l'un des journalistes du
Figaro à infiltré un stage réélien
pendant une semaine et il est avec moi
sur ce plateau pour tout nous raconter
bonjour étienne Jacob bonjour Thibault
alors Étienne vous nous proposez un
reportage en trois fois c'est ça la
première partie a été publiée vendredi
dernier je la montre d'ailleurs elle est
ici vous pouvez déjà la retrouver tout à
fait j'ai infiltré la secteur l pendant
une semaine voici deuxième épisode dans
une heure c'est ça
on parle de quoi cette fois précisément
détaillez nous cette fois on va parler
du du jeune on a une journée de jeûne
qui était prévue dans ce dans ce stage
d'éveil et donc ce sera pratiquement ça
et l'intervention de Raël qui était en
visioconférence depuis depuis Okinawa et
donc c'était vraiment ce les deux les
deux temps qui seront racontés dans cet
article voilà et puis il faudra attendre
la semaine suivante vendredi prochain
pour avoir la troisième partie de la
c'est sûr le financement
bon on s'y met comment vous est venu
cette idée déjà vous avez une appétence
pour les sectes quand même hein un petit
peu un petit peu ce que vous avez je
rappelle que vous avez écrit un livre la
famille qui parle de cette mystérieuse
communauté qui est sectaire là aussi
tout à fait tout à fait la famille une
grande communauté qui est dans l'est
parisien et c'est vrai que bon j'ai une
appétence pour pour les secs depuis
quelques quelques années et concernant
réel c'est vrai que c'est une secte dont
on parlait il y a il y a plusieurs
dizaines d'années
90 c'est pas vraiment une une secte dont
on parle aujourd'hui et il se trouve que
pendant le covid on fait parler d'eux
ils offraient des câlins gratuits en
cause évidemment tout ce qui était
vaccination covid machinations parce
qu'il y a quand même un côté très
complotiste dans dans cette dans ce
mouvement là donc je me suis intéressé à
eux et j'ai découvert que sur leur site
des organisé une université du bonheur
d'accord cet été donc j'ai décidé
d'aller sur le site
d'ailleurs tout le monde peut trouver
très facilement ça j'imagine ils ont une
catégorie événement et en fait
voilà il y avait cet événement qui était
prévu je me suis dit bon ça sera
vraiment l'occasion d'essayer de voir
comment ils sont est-ce qu'ils sont
encore très actifs et faire une
immersion pourquoi pour essayer
d'obtenir les meilleurs les meilleurs
témoignages parce que si on va leur
parler en tant que journaliste ce sera
clairement pas pareil reconnaissant ces
mouvements là ils sont quand même très
hostiles à tout ce qui est médias et
presse traditionnels alors comment on
monte une infiltration pareil qu'elles
ont été vos contacts vous envoyez un
mail simplement bah j'envoie un mail
déjà choisi une fausse identité je
rappelle plus Étienne je m'appelle
Julien d'accord Julien enchanté
bienvenue agent immobilier d'accord
voilà et donc tous se backgrin là se
construit se construit petit à petit
j'envoie un mail à un des un des un des
organisateurs du du
du stage et en fait donc vous faites une
forme de légende je pense à ça vous êtes
un espion infiltré donc comme vous vous
réfléchissez au moindre détail de votre
vie vous avez des frères et soeurs où on
va peut-être pas à ce point-là bah en
fait je reprends ma personnalité je
change quand même le métier parce que
c'est un métier que je connais bien
auprès de mes proches et après voilà
j'ai j'ai vraiment j'y suis allé quand
même en étant moi-même avec quand même
une histoire
parce que la question qu'on posait les
raeliens c'est comment ça ça m'intéresse
comment vous avez découvert que vous
étiez à héliens c'est ça voilà à
expliquer le c'est je le lis dans le
dans la première partie et je le
remontre mais vous pouvez nous expliquer
là bien sûr donc en fait j'ai j'étais au
travail on travaille d'agent immobilier
et j'ai noté sur mon petit carnet
j'étais au téléphone et vous savez quand
ton téléphone parfois on se on se met à
griffonner où on marche en ne marchant
pas sur les lignes des carreaux
machinalement voilà et donc j'ai dessiné
une croix gammée bon je dessine croix
gammée et mon collègue mon collègue
vient me voir et il me dit mais mais
cette croix gammée enfin tu tu es fou de
faire ça enfin ne fais pas ça et donc ça
c'était mon histoire et après moi
j'étais persuadé donc mon personnage
était persuadé que la croix gamine
n'était pas qu'un symbole nazi et été
aussi un symbole peut-être positif et
j'ai recherché sur internet et je suis
tombé sur elle et effectivement le logo
le symbole de réel c'est une une croix
gammée enfin un vastica avec avec
cette histoire elle a fasciné le groupe
quand je suis arrivé et j'ai été obligé
de la de la dérouler dès le premier jour
au bout de je t'invite depuis 30 minutes
je pense je me suis retrouvé dans
l'herbe on essaie on s'est assis en rond
et on m'a dit et toi comment tu nous as
connu j'avais prévu mais je pensais pas
que ce serait d'un coup comme ça et
c'était vrai que c'était pas évident
mais bon j'ai l'impression que plus
c'est gros plus ça passe donc c'est très
bien passé mais alors vous avez jamais
rencontré avant personne vous avez juste
fermé donc vous a dit viens
en fait on m'a dit viens après on m'a
dit il y a des possibilités
d'hébergement
on m'a pas répondu tout de suite donc au
début j'ai un peu laissé tomber le truc
puis on est revenu vers moi on m'a dit
que ça coûtera 260 euros pour les
quelques jours ce qui est pas exorbitant
pour le coup le mouvement de fonctionne
pas sur le sur les bergement je pense et
voilà et en fait ça c'est fait assez
facilement j'ai eu deux coups de fil et
j'ai été j'ai déjà joué un peu le
personnage du du jeune homme un peu
perdu qui peut éventuellement tomber
dans un mouvement comme ça et je pense
que c'est très vite passé vous réagissez
évidemment sur Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
je salue les habitués Christian néon
Toussaint qui est déjà là que ça
intéresse je le sais vous réagissez vous
n'hésitez pas je suis avec Etienne Jacob
qui a infiltré une secte réelle et qui
fait un reportage en trois fois la
deuxième partie c'est dans à peu près
une heure alors
vous êtes convié finalement ça se passe
sous qu'est-ce que c'est ce petit stage
là oui alors ça se passe à ça se passe à
la Chaise Dieu c'est en Haute-Loire
c'est un petit village un peu perdu en
Haute-Loire et donc dans un camping le
Camping a accepté de des berger les
rails le camping ne savait pas que
c'était derrière
l'épisode mais mais voilà donc j'ai
débarqué là dedans et c'était c'était
vraiment en Vasco parce qu'il y avait
plus de 200 personnes qui étaient quand
même conviées donc sachant qu'on en a
plus de 200 le camping avait
pratiquement que des raeliens à savoir
que les Rayan n'avaient pas le droit de
parler aux personnel du camping d'accord
il y avait un seul référent il fallait
bon ça c'était un peu un peu intrigant
déjà ça m'a ça a commencé à me poser
question il y avait cette histoire de on
va vous faire entrer dans un stage de
cinq jours et on vous met en vaselot
pour pouvoir vous parler vous faire
comprendre des choses faire passer des
messages on voit ces photos toutes les
photos que nous voyons ici
c'est vous qui les avez prises sans que
ce soit forcément à chaque fois autorisé
on vend on va en parler donc ça coûte
combien vous me dites 280 euros 260 je
crois c'est c'est donc c'était oui
c'était le montant surtout de
l'hébergement donc là on vous parle pas
d'argent finalement pas trop au début
mais pas du tout aucun moment avant les
deux derniers jours en fait alors tout
le monde n'est pas au même niveau il y a
des bracelets c'est ça oui alors quand
on arrive on nous remet quand on est
nouveau on nous remet un petit cahier
qu'on voit à l'image d'accord moi un
porte-clés voilà des goodies et un
bracelet et en fait les nouveaux ont un
bracelet donc qui est violet pour tout
le monde mais il y a un petit un autre
petit morceau de bracelet qui est vert
pour les pour ceux qui sont
novices d'accord vous voilà et ça permet
à tous ceux qui sont anciens de voir que
il y a des nouveaux et d'aller les voir
et c'est ça qui m'a surpris en premier
lieu c'est que les personnes viennent
vous voir toutes les toutes les deux
minutes pour vous faire des câlins pour
vous faire des embrasser de fille quand
même toujours surprenant dans une
période post covid
et c'est vrai que bon c'était quand même
surprenant et et oui il y a toujours ce
ce côté de ne jamais laisser la personne
seule pour gamberger on vous prend sous
leurs ailes finalement et on se sent
tellement choyé on se sent aimé mais
c'est c'est très perturbant et je pense
que la plupart des gens pourraient se
laisser prendre au jeu parce que des
personnes seules imaginer ouais ça
m'intéresse et on va en parler pour
l'instant je veux que vous nous raconter
ce qui s'est passé mais après je veux
votre ressenti personnel c'est un moment
vous êtes dit tiens est-ce que les
extraterrestres peuvent arriver non on
va on parler un peu plus tard on voit
qui dans ce genre de stage quel est le
quels sont les personnalité c'est des
jeunes des personnes plus âgées quelle
classe sociale des hommes des femmes
dites-moi c'est quoi le profil du
raelien je sais pas si un profil du
rainien mais en tout cas bon réel a
rencontré enfin dit avoir rencontré les
les extraterrestres nos créateurs les
éloïnes dans les années 70 donc il se
trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont adhéré dans les années suivantes
parce qu'il a fait énormément de de pub
à ce moment-là ça marche ça marchait
énormément il y avait pas Internet les
gens étaient quand même moins
globalement moins informés même si
aujourd'hui ils sont souvent désinformés
et donc c'est vrai que il y a un profil
du railien qui sont des personnes
maintenant un peu âgées on a des
personnes de 60 ans 70 ans tu as
beaucoup de personnes qui sont en barbe
en barbe en qui essaient de reproduire
un peu le profil de Raël qu'on voit ici
voilà les les un peu les longs cheveux
et souvent il y a quand même un profil
de de baba cool si on peut dire
68 heures un peu plus qui fait que voilà
où à l'époque des mouvements les
religions
classique traditionnel n’était pas
forcément en odeur bien vu il y avait
vraiment ce mouvement d'essayer de
trouver une autre voix et Raël a
beaucoup recruté à ce moment-là donc les
c'est vrai que les membres les membres
du mouvement sont souvent ceux de la
première heure après il y a une seconde
vague qui arrivait dans les années 90
donc on a une tranche de personnes 45
ans et une tranche plutôt 60 70 qui vous
êtes combien à peu près dans ce stage là
on est un peu plus de 200 je pense
est-ce que c'est 200 sont l'ensemble des
raeliens français pas du tout pas du
tout parce que évidemment il faut avoir
les moyens pour pour financer le stage
je me suis pas extrêmement onéreux donc
non non il y a pas il y a pas tout le
monde faut savoir que avant la période
du covid les réeliens se réunissaient
toutes les années
souvent en Europe d'ailleurs pas
forcément en France c'est 20 dernières
années c'était surtout en Croatie en
Slovénie se réunissait et il y avait
tous les réhésiens de l'Europe et
parfois c'était des rêves semblablement
à plusieurs milliers de personnes donc
là ils étaient que 200 parce que ce
n'était que un RA francophones
et c'est aussi après trois ans sans rien
bon je pense que voilà il y a eu
peut-être l'idée du nombre de
d'adhérents
on peut pas savoir c'est très dur c'est
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
France dans le monde ça prend à de
nombreux endroits en Afrique c'est très
populaire je pense que c'est maintenant
plus populaire qu'en France et il y a
aussi une communauté en Asie
particulièrement au Japon pourquoi parce
que Claude vorillon est et là-bas il est
à Okinawa alors j'ai vu l'Asie et le
Japon surtout est assez
soft et plutôt bienveillant avec les
secs par exemple la secte Moon on sait
que le l'ancien président Premier
ministre d'ailleurs AB a été assassiné
par un adepte de la secte Moon on laisse
faire les sectes au Japon bah c'est
toujours c'est toujours la France a une
spécialité aussi de d'être un pays
laïque au Japon c'est vrai qu'on laisse
plus faire
je pense qu'il y a aussi une volonté du
côté de du moment indien de de se dire
assez proche tout ce qui est bouddhisme
qui effectivement la basse ça ne choque
pas
il n'empêche que malgré tout on a tout
un discours derrière qui est quand même
assez toxique étienne Jacob a infiltré
la secte Raël pendant une semaine il
nous parle de son stage chez les ryens
vous pouvez retrouver le premier épisode
déjà sur le site internet le deuxième ça
arrive dans un peu moins d'une heure et
puis le troisième c'est vendredi
prochain vous faites quoi dans ce stage
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors dites-moi et
ben on commence le matin on a une
méditation souvent on nous assomme de la
méditation donc le matin on se lève
quand même très tôt on a de la
méditation on nous fait nous réveiller
nous connecter avec l'infini il y a
toujours se connecter avec ces fameux
créateurs ces fameuses hellohim il faut
toujours être connecté avec eux donc
c'est une méditation et classique donc
je pense pas que ce soit quelque chose
de très nocif hormis peut-être la forme
qui est un peu originale et puis surtout
il y avait la une salle de cours qui
s'appelait l'Olympe d'accord en fait
c'est un gymnase qui était aménagé pour
l'occasion
on le verra sur les sur les images et
donc dans cet endroit là on nous tout un
tas d'enseignements et l'idée du stage
c'était de faire un escalier de l'éveil
c'est à dire on nous parlait de
l'Université du bonheur mais en fait
c'était un stage d'éveil et dont nous a
fait bien fait comprendre dès le début
que c'était un stage d'éveil le but
c'était que que notre conscience
s'éveille face à ce monde qui est
toxique qui nous laisse pas faire ce
qu'on veut un discours tout anti-système
c'est clairement ça et le premier la
première marche l'Olympe voilà c'est ça
l'Olympe avec un grand un écran géant on
parle avec des avec des avec des
orateurs qui sont quand même pour le
coup très bon d'accord qui qui seraient
capables d'embobiner un peu n'importe
qui ça c'est une des séances de
méditation et en fait comme ça hein
c'est ça on l'a fait
ça vous donne envie de rire vous êtes là
dedans mais tout le monde a explosé de
rire à ce moment c'était tout à la fin
qu'on nous a fait faire ça et on
découvrira dans le troisième épisode
mais c'est on nous a fait faire ça et il
y a un des hommes qui étaient un nouveau
qui s'est tordu de rire par terre mais
pour vous dire en 10 minutes il était en
transe en fait et tout le monde était
surpris mais c'est vrai que et ce
monsieur j'en parle dans le premier
épisode c'est ce monsieur qui est aussi
un peu magnétiseur et qui se target de
pouvoir un peu soigner tout le monde
donc j'ai une question prenait cette
cette tasse à vous la prenez la main
droite
j'ai vu que vous étiez gaucher dans
votre partage tout à fait alors quand je
me ferais je vous parlais tout à l'heure
du moment où je me présente je me suis
présenté dans l'herbe avec tout le monde
et effectivement à ce moment là on a
princesse Luna princesse Luna c'est la
parole c'est la porte-parole du
mouvement réélien et cette cette dame là
qui doit avoir à peu près 50 ans
aujourd'hui
elle est habituée des médias elle avait
été invité chez Ardisson il y a
plusieurs années elle sait quand même
faire et la première chose qu'elle m'a
dit c'est est-ce que tu es gaucher elle
fait oui je l'avais remarqué donc oui je
suis gaucher et elle m'a fait oui je
l'avais remarqué beaucoup de rééliens
sont gauchés d'accord donc on voit des
cerveaux gauche le cerveau gauche le
cerveau plus qui ne réfléchit pas parce
que le premier escalier de l'éveil c'est
ne pas penser on nous dit posez votre
cerveau alors on a un vrai problème
quand je vous lis chez les raeliens avec
l'éducation l'école on déteste ça on
n'aime pas les gens éduqués chez les
liens ben en fait on parle on estime que
ce qui est bien c'est là et que
aujourd'hui dans notre société on nous
fait faire on nous fait aller dans des
filières plutôt de bureau plutôt que
d'exploiter son esprit artistique et
donc on préfère cet esprit artistique
qui doit être inné c'est à dire qu'on ne
doit pas réfléchir à ce qu'on dit parce
que la pensée elle pollue
réelle dans une des premières vidéos
qu'on nous a projeté nous dit stopper
cette machine infernale qu'elle a pensé
donc il faut poser sa pensée mais poser
sa pensée ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
aussi potentiellement ne se faire avoir
par n'importe qui dont le mouvement
radiant on entend bien évidemment ce que
vous nous dites c'est une Jacob qui a
infiltré je le répète et je le remontre
la secte rail mouvement aérien pendant
une semaine pour un stage
on peut peut-être reprendre depuis le
début réel Claude c'est qui qui est ce
type bah c'est un homme qui a été
vraiment un toucher à tout il a il a
tout fait dans sa vie il était
journaliste automobile il a il a même
fait des courses auto à haut niveau
c'est un monsieur qui a qui a toujours
voulu un petit peu la lumière d'accord
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
ressort de son de son personnage et
je pense que son voilà il a eu du mal à
trouver sa voie il a été aussi musicien
beaucoup musicien c'est quelque chose
qui qui le dit dans ces vidéos c'est que
la musique c'est très important parce
que la musique c'est innée les vrais
artistes je suis allé chercher un peu
sur internet je le vois donner des
concerts même hein
bien sûr il était il était il avait sa
petite renommée mais c'était pas non
plus une star à ce moment-là donc
un ex raidien avait raconté il y a
quelques années qu'en fait
tout le comment dire tout imaginaire
autour de elle l'histoire de j'ai
rencontré des extraterrestres un beau
jour en 1973 d'accord ça y est ont été
inventé le jour d'une soirée trop
arrosée donc bon
est-ce que Raël croit en ce qui dit je
pense que c'est un business moi je pense
qu'il y croit je pense qu'à force ça
fait 50 ans qu'il qu'il développe son
argumentaire sa rhétorique elle est
hyper rodée c'est un monsieur qui a un
vocabulaire hyper simple compréhensible
de tous et c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui
il y croit et ça a permis je pense de
rendre le personnage plus crédible pour
certains même si quand on est à
l'extérieur on voilà on a quand même de
mal à adhérer comment il a pu exploser
comme ça aux yeux du monde qu'est-ce
qu'il fait que à l'époque vous me dites
il y a pas internet on invite dans les
médias comment il commence à penser se
diffuse il a fait des livres il a fait
beaucoup de livres j'ai rencontré les
extra-terrestres les messages des
éloïnes et ces fameux messages en fait
prodiguent finalement des conseils de
vie assez simple on nous les a martelés
pendant le pendant le stage que tout le
monde pourrait auquel tout le monde
pourrait adhérer c'est à dire ne pas
trop boire avoir une vie saine ce qui
fait qu'on forme de développement
personnel voilà il y a tout un côté
développement personnel et ça a plu à
beaucoup de gens et ils ont vu ça comme
une vraiment comme une autre voix
possible et c'est vrai que ça ça a
énormément fonctionné jusque au début
des années 2000 où il y a eu une énorme
polémique sur le clonage alors oui on va
en reparler de cette polémique sur le
tournage c'est pour ça qu'il a quitté la
France et la Suisse d'ailleurs ce qu'il
est franco-suisse hein c'est ça ouais il
est né en France mais en France il a
plus le droit d'être il exilé au Japon
il est pas il est pas vraiment exilé je
sais qu'il était plutôt personnel mon
gratin en Suisse et il a eu des des
problèmes je crois
en revanche il n'est pas interdit de
territoire en France mais il sait que
son mouvement ne prend plus vraiment en
France donc il a voulu partir ailleurs
et puis avoir aussi tout cet imaginaire
du prophète dont personne ne veut ça
entretient aussi le personnage il est
là-bas il nous parle même s'il est loin
de nous donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est
ouais c'est tout un tout un scénario un
décorum je dirais plutôt qui qui a été
mis en place et qui est ouais qui
aujourd'hui continue de fonctionner même
si on en parle peu parlez-nous de ce
qu'il s'est passé au début des années
2000 après on revient à votre
infiltration le clonage j'ai lu La
possibilité d'une île de Houellebecq oui
est-ce que c'est exactement ça c'est ça
peut ressembler en vérité
d'ailleurs les Rayan prenaient
Houellebecq comme comme exemple un
moment donné et le portait au nu et à un
moment donné où elle Bek a dit non non
je ne suis pas je mange pas de ce pain
là donc voilà il y a eu cette polémique
sur le clonage il se trouve que Raël
dans dans toute son organisation qui
organisations très hiérarchique a créé
des sociétés et avait créé une société
qui s'appelait clonade d'accord elle a
été créé par Raël et par une dame qui
s'appelait Brigitte Boisselier et donc
ces personnes on dit que cette société
était faite pour essayer d'entreprendre
le premier clonage humain et un beau
jour Brigitte Boisselier a déclaré
devant tout le monde que elle avait
réussi le premier clonage humain donc
tout le monde a attendu l'épreuve elle a
même été auditionné par le Congrès
américain
il a jamais aucune preuve qui est venu
et j'en ai parlé un petit peu au monde
pendant mon infiltration et ça c'était
assez je pense que c'est on veut plus en
parler j'ai l'impression on veut pas
trop en parler et quand on en parle on
dit on sait pas ah ok peut-être que il y
a pas de preuve mais bon il y a pas eu
de preuve peut-être que c'est vrai
peut-être que c'est faux personne n'a
démontré l'inverse c'est toujours la on
inverse la charge de la preuve c'est
toujours le côté un petit peu
conspirationniste qui fait que bah au
final est-ce que tu peux me dire que
j'ai vraiment tort démontre le moi alors
qu'en fait c'est l'inverse qui devrait
être alors justement vous avez utilisé
le bon mot conspirationniste je lis
quand même vos messages parce que ça
fait toujours un peu sourire il y a du
monde Nathan j'ai infiltré le forum du
figue oui vous avez bien fait vous
n'hésitez pas Red est un malin tout
simplement on nous dit oui sans doute
sans doute peu de monde j'imagine croire
que elle vraiment très en lien avec les
extraterrestres conspirationnisme
complotisme c'est la nouvelle vague sur
laquelle surf Raël ou finalement c'est
un précurseur de tout ça je pense que
c'est un précurseur parce qu'il y avait
vraiment ce côté développement personnel
aujourd'hui on sait que les les
mouvements à caractère sectaire sont
très actifs dans le domaine de la santé
du bien-être et remarque que les membres
sont extrêmement à fond là-dedans enfin
c'est c'est impressionnant on a tout un
tas de personnes qui ne mangent que
crues et ça on sait que c'est quelque
chose qui est prôné notamment par le
youtubeur Thierry casasnovas qui est
visé par une information judiciaire pour
pour exercer illégal de la médecine donc
il y a toujours et voilà il trempe un
petit peu dans tous ces mouvements là le
manger cru le jeune on le découvrira
dans l'épisode mais c'est vrai que le
jeune est quelque chose de voilà de très
vendu je pense pas d'ailleurs que le
jeune une une journée parfois est
mauvais mais là on nous le vend vraiment
comme comme une pratique
importante donc d'accord donc c'est vrai
qu'il y a tout un tas de il y a toute
cette mouvance et puis si je vous dis la
Russie si je vous dis le vaccin on coche
toutes les cases là qu'on peut utiliser
tout va tout ça tout ça et ça c'est ça
c'est Raël qui le dit ça c'est ça qui
est important parce que le troisième
jour c'est ça et on lira dans dans
l'épisode qui qui vient là d'ici une
demi-heure et vous pouvez retrouver sur
le figure au point fr vous avez vu Raël
vous parlez en vrai
ouais ouais il est venu en
visioconférence ça a été tout un c'était
une surprise faut savoir que c'était le
début de notre jeune donc on commençait
déjà être faible il était à peu près
midi etrel
rien avait été annoncé on vous prépare
une petite surprise on me disait et Raël
est venu en visioconférence évidemment
il est au Japon mais ça a été tout un
décorum parce que de nombreuses femmes
de la communauté se sont habillés en
conséquence à l'époque ça devait être
encore plus encore plus expansif mais
elles étaient habillées assez légèrement
et elles étaient et quand il est arrivé
ça a été vraiment les applaudissements
comme comme jamais quoi ah c'est
vraiment une star et là il arrive pour
faire son son show et même si on nous
dit qu'il ne faut pas l'idolâtrer en
vérité il y a quand même il y a quand
même quelque chose de ce type et donc là
il vous tient un discours antivax pro
Poutine totalement il
c'est une énumération
quand même de propos qui qui dépasse
l'entendement
c'est ça ça ne sert pas son personnage
et j'ai même pu discuté avec des
personnes qui trouvaient ça un peu
dommage
épisode vous dites les gens sortent de
là bon ils aiment bien le développement
personnel la méditation mais la partie
antivax est complotisme pas forcément
voilà il y a et surtout il n'aime pas
forcément c'est c'est ouais ce discours
aussi antisocial alors que à côté on
nous dit que il faut donner de l'amour
plutôt que donner de l'argent dans ce
monde-là parce que il y a faut savoir
que Raël a mis en place tout un tas
enfin à comment tu as plutôt à à
mis en place tout un tas de de concepts
depuis 50 ans notamment la géniocratie
on devrait donner on devrait une société
où on ne où on ne ou seuls les personnes
avec un quotient intellectuel le plus
élevé pourrait avoir le droit de voter
des conseils c'est pas le seul à penser
ça je pense à Aymeric Caron qui avait
proposé ça par exemple et ben très bien
avec
[Musique]
c'est qu'ils sont tellement convaincus
de ça que au bout d'un moment est-ce
qu'il est bonne orateur lui dit quand il
vous parle comme je disais il parle il
parle très simplement donc ça c'est
plutôt agréable parce que on peut voilà
c'est efficace après c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on sent que il se cherche
un peu sur toute cette histoire
on en parlait il y a la Russie il y a le
vaccin le réchauffement climatique
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit que le CO2 les
plantes en avaient besoin alors
qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit que il y a un
problème de réchauffement climatique
voilà c'est c'est il remet en cause tous
ce qui est admis on va dire par la
communauté scientifique même si le
mouvement assure que la science est très
bien ils sont quand même très antis tout
ce qui est admis vous avez évidemment
besoin de prendre des notes de ce qu'il
dit vous avez besoin de prendre des
photos et je montre certaines d'entre
elles comment vous faites là vous
retenez tout comment ça se passe alors
au début j'ai tout retenu c'était pas
facile et puis j'ai franchement je pense
qu'ils m'ont bien aidé il donne un
carnet on a vu dans les photos qui qui
tournent ils donnent un carnet et en
fait vu que ce sont des enseignements
tous les rails notent ils notent les
enseignements comme de bons élèves donc
moi évidemment il faut que nous vous
abonner bien noté évidemment j'ai bien
bien noté j'ai même enregistré un moment
donné où je n'avais pas mon cahier et
bon ça c'était pas vraiment autorisé
entre guillemets mais oui il y a
beaucoup de prises de notes qui a pu se
faire et ça ça m'a quand même bien aidé
par contre dans les contacts que j'ai eu
avec les rats et liens en tant que tel
lors du dîner lors du lors des après les
méditations les moments on va dire entre
les cours là c'était vraiment il fallait
retenir c'était pas évident est-ce que
vous avez des moments où en tant que
journaliste immergé
vous mettez à croire à certaines choses
bah écoutez je pense qu'on voilà bon vu
que je connais quand même bien ce ces
domaines là je peux pas dire que je que
j'y crois par contre on peut vraiment se
dire que n'importe qui peut se faire
avoir et ça c'est quand même préoccupant
je trouve de dire que Ben
on vous a tellement donné d'amour si
vous êtes perdus dans votre vie moi je
sais que j'ai rencontré un jeune homme
qui avait à peu près mon âge ce gars là
il était
au chômage il avait pas grand chose dans
sa vie on sentait que c'était quelqu'un
de très timide il avait des petits
problèmes d'élocution c'était difficile
pour lui et on lui a donné tellement
d'amour mais jamais il s'en ira il doit
être trop content on lui donne de
l'amour on prend de ses nouvelles on lui
dit que ça va et en plus on lui donne on
va dire un guide de vie
mais malheureusement derrière bon il y a
une volonté qui est pas forcément
positive mais pour lui là en ce moment
vu qu'il faisait partie des nouveaux
c'est quelque chose de d'incroyable donc
effectivement je pense que ça peut être
très nocif et d'ailleurs le rapport
Guyard qui est un rapport sur les sectes
dans les années 2000 à Clermont dit que
le mouvement réélien faisait partie des
mouvements sectaires j'ai tendance à
faire attention pour caractériser des
mouvements de secte mais là on est
clairement dans un mouvement de ce type
16h30 nous sommes en direct étienne
Jacob journaliste Figaro un infiltré
pendant une semaine un stage d'une des
sectes rails il nous raconte tout ça
d'ailleurs comment on
qualifie un mouvement de secte est-ce
qu'on peut le préciser c'est difficile
bah ce rapport Guyard un petit peu donné
une définition
c'est vrai que voilà il ils ont dans le
rapport on dit que il n'y a pas de
définition mais on donne un faisceau
d'indice c'est à dire qu'il y a une
dizaine de critères qui permettent
d'évaluer si oui ou non un mouvement est
une secte
il suffit pas d'avoir les 10 sur les 10
pour que ce soit considéré comme une
secte il suffit d'en avoir quatre ou
cinq et qu'il soit suffisamment fort
pour à peu près considérer que c'est une
secte après vous mettre dans le dire que
c'est une secte ou pas ça ne change rien
c'est un c'est mon tique bien sûr mais
donc il y a parmi ces faisceaux
d'indices il y a un groupe une personne
un guide un gourou un chef d'accord avec
euh totalement il y a le côté argent
c'est à dire qu'on est en argent encore
parlé de l'argent ça en fait partie et
il y a aussi ce côté antisocial par
rapport ce discours contre le système
anti-système anti
anti-toux finalement et voilà ça fait
partie c'est les trois gros critères il
y a aussi le problème des enfants alors
je ne l'ai pas vu lors de mon stage
parce que c'était plutôt un auditoire
âgé mais autrefois Raël prenait
l'éducation sexuelle dès le plus jeune
âge donc il y a aussi une impact sur les
enfants donc ça peut aussi rentrer dans
ce cadre là et il y a aussi le trouble à
l'ordre public alors aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas vraiment de troupes de la part des
railiens
tout à fait il y a plus en avoir par le
passé et il y a eu des procès parce
qu'il y a eu des problèmes de de
harcèlement
voir des histoires d'agression sexuelle
lors de ces stages ces fameux stages qui
à l'époque duraient encore plus
longtemps Chris Kross qui ne dit bonjour
monsieur veut des sectes oui il nous
raconte c'est un habitué avec Chris
cross perso il y a 20 ans j'ai fait
l'erreur de mettre les pieds par hasard
dans la Scientologie pour un test de
personnalité
erreur fatale ils n'ont pas arrêté de me
harceler et moi pendant des mois voilà
ce qu'il ce qu'il nous dit est-ce que un
moment dans votre immersion vous avez
peur
Etienne d'être découvert un peu tout le
temps en fait j'avais tout le temps peur
d'être découvert surtout au début parce
que c'est vrai qu'au début il faut
d'abord on va dire
au bout d'un moment vous dites pas bah
tiens ça y est je suis dedans et vous
vous laissez porter vous rentrez dans le
personnage mais si je vous appelle
Étienne vous répondez vous entendez
Étienne vous tournez la tête alors votre
nom rappelle là-bas sur place c'est
Julien Julien mais je peux vous dire que
si je vous appelle Richard vous ne
répondrez pas même si vous avez bien
bossé le personnage et donc c'est ça
c'était très difficile plusieurs fois je
me suis fait avoir on m'a appelé et je
me suis trompé aussi de reprise je me
suis trompé j'ai dit je m'appelle
Étienne à deux à deux personnes
séparément une tout à fait tellement
naturel une toute à la fin et une au
début et un monsieur au début mais il se
trouve qu'en fait je pense que ça n'a
pas il n'a pas compris pourquoi parce
que là-bas beaucoup de personnes
n'utilisent pas leur vrai prénom ah donc
ça vous arrange voilà il y en avait un
qui s'appelait ISAE c'était un prénom
japonais justement et qui voilà c'est
pas son vrai prénom et donc je pense que
voilà pour eux c'est pas important et
c'est surtout pas important ce qu'est la
personne à l'extérieur
ah oui c'est à dire que vous êtes ici
dans la secte enfin dans la secte danse
oui dans la secte des danses stages vous
faites ce que vous voulez ailleurs et si
vous êtes un réel voilà on est un réel
lien on est une personne et évidemment
on nous vend ce discours vous êtes tous
égaux et aussi rien n'est obligatoire si
vous en avez marre des enseignements il
y a pas de problème mais ça c'est un peu
une façade on vous dit ça mais on vous
souffle un peu le vent chaud froid en
vous disant il faut faire ça mais vous
inquiétez pas vous pouvez même pas le
faire par contre tout le monde va le
faire donc vous allez aussi le faire
Etienne vous me révélez rien de ce qui
s'est passé parce que j'ai lu jusqu'à la
fin j'ai eu la chance moi de pouvoir
lire déjà le troisième épisode ne me
révélez rien mais est-ce que vous avez
peur
d'être découvert est-ce que je veux dire
qu'est-ce que vous risquez vraiment en
étant découvert est-ce que vous le
sentez ce que vous le savez
en fait on sait pas vraiment mais ils
ont peut-être des gens violents on sent
pas des gens violents au contraire on a
plutôt l'impression que ce sont des gens
à la cool en revanche
il y a tellement ce discours qui est
contre cette société cette société qui
vous
qui vous formatent on parle d'éducation
de la conscience et du castration
c'est donc
vous en tant que
journaliste vous êtes quand même un
ennemi
on n'aime pas du tout les médias on
aimerait rien de de ce qui est on va
dire dans le dans le dans le cursus
classique donc c'est vrai que le
journaliste est quand même vu quand même
quelque chose de plutôt hostile et il se
trouve que si beaucoup de personnes sont
très bienveillantes d'autres parfois ont
un discours tellement il y a tellement
de rancoeurs de la part de ces gens on a
l'impression qu'ils ont pas fait ce
qu'ils voulaient dans la vie à un moment
donné ils sont pas heureux que
que quand même c'est c'est on se dit que
si on se fait découvrir ça peut ça peut
mal tourner
pardon pour cette question mais en
lisant tout ce qui s'est fait autour de
elle il y a une grande part au sexe la
sexualité et au naturisme est-ce que
vous avez dû vous mettre nu est-ce que
il y a la question du sexe qui revient
je sais pas je il y a peut-être une
sorte de fantasme pour nous qui ne
connaissons rien de ce qui peut se
passer dans ces stages là oui alors donc
en fait en vérité un des mantras de réel
c'est la méditation sensuelle
donc on a fait de la méditation la
médiation sensuelle ça va être vous
ressentez votre corps votre votre sexe
votre plexus solaire bon rien finalement
qui va aller au delà je pense que le
fait que l'auditoire soit plus âgée fait
qu'aujourd'hui
tout le côté sexuel est passé quand même
sur un second plan en tout cas moi j'ai
pas vu vraiment quelque chose comme ça
après on nous a quand même fait faire
des méditations en nous disant bah
massez-vous là massez-vous
les hanches massez-vous le bas du ventre
mais mais vraiment de manière ça fait
rire tout le monde à ce moment là donc
c'est vrai qu'on prend pas vraiment au
sérieux
en revanche il y avait une sexologue qui
était qui faisait partie des guides
d'accord j'ai vu qu'il a été sexologue
ensuite et cette fille là elle avait
toujours elle était elle est toujours
tendance à sexualiser ce qu'elle disait
elle nous faisait faire les méditations
mais c'était toujours avec une voix très
douce très sexualisée et il faut dire
également qu'elle nous a fait un cours
qui était pas forcément le cours le plus
intéressant qui qui était sur sur
l'orgasme cosmique c'est à dire qu'il
fallait toujours être en connexion avec
quand avec les éloïdes pour en fait les
l'acte sexuel doit toujours être fait en
conscience que qu'on est tout petit par
rapport à ses créateurs donc
ça existe mais c'est pas non plus le la
chose la plus prégnante que j'ai que
j'ai vu lors de mon stage on parle
d'argent un peu parce que c'est l'une
des questions évidemment avec ces gens
qui sont embrigadés sur tout ça qui peut
poser un problème comment réel gagne de
l'argent vous me dites que vous n'avez
quasiment rien payé vous j'ai payé mon
séjour mais je pense que je l'ai payé
directement au camping en revanche il se
trouve que vers la fin du séjour on a
commencé à devenir assistant auprès de
moi j'étais nouveau donc on m'a dit
est-ce que tu vas vouloir faire ta
transmission du plan cellulaire
qu'est-ce que c'est la transmission du
plan cellulaire c'est technique ce terme
le baptême en fait c'est d'accord c'est
ce qui te permet de devenir ce qui
permet de devenir membre de devenir
raelien j'ai mis j'ai mis les freins
pourquoi parce que avec ce transmis
cette transmission du plan cellulaire
qui est une cérémonie un peu un peu un
peu baptême on a tout un côté qui va
être sur bah tu vas devoir aussi donner
un pourcentage de ton salaire alors tu
peux donner 15% mais il y a bon je l'ai
pas vu vraiment parce que je l'ai pas vu
totalement mais il y a le pourcentage
qu'on va donner au mouvement en France à
l'international et au final ça peut vite
faire beaucoup et on nous on plaisante à
la scène on nous dit mais si vous voulez
donner 100%, il y a pas de problème et
réel a une rhétorique qui est incroyable
qui nous dit je vous donne la
possibilité de donner c'est à dire oui
c'est non non
en général je ne veux pas mais je vous
donne aujourd'hui la possibilité de
donner c'est à dire que si je disais non
vous ne pourriez pas donner donc
aujourd'hui vous offre le privilège de
données savez-vous m'avoir envoyé c'est
incroyable
non mais c'est à dire que ça inverse
encore une fois le système et évidemment
les gens donnent alors on prélève sur le
salaire c'est clair que le salaire tombe
là vous êtes au Figaro vous avez votre
salaire tous les mois et il y a un
pourcentage qui part directement chez
sherl c'est ça et en vérité il y avait
des petites enveloppes qui ont qui ont
commencé à traverser dans la dans la
salle lors des derniers jours avec des
simplement des mandats sepas donc c'est
un mandat qui permet de prélever tous
les mois librement au mouvement voilà
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des personnes plus
âgées vous parlez d'un homme de 70 ans
il y a depuis le début ou presque et il
ne progresse jamais dans la hiérarchie
laisse les jambes c'est un système qui
est très hiérarchique les railiens et il
y a des guides et les guides sont très
chaleureux à l'extérieur et très très
chaleureux pardon pendant pendant les
cours ils sont très expansifs très bon
en revanche dès qu'on sort de ce de ce
de ces cours-là ils deviennent très
froid et ce monsieur lui n'a jamais eu
l'occasion de devenir
guide ce qui est donc le le niveau
dessus on va dire et ces gens qui
peuvent permettre de voilà de dispenser
ces fameux cours et ce monsieur là il
est resté tout le temps dans le
mouvement bah à bas niveau et il a l'air
d'être bien en fait il a tous les
accessoires tous ces le livre qu'on voit
sur le diapo qu'on a passé tout à
l'heure et celui-ci il était venu avec
il était il avait tout son attirail et
ce monsieur m'a ma surprise parce que
pour lui c'est ça fait tellement 50 ans
qu'il est dedans que c'est sûr en fait
il y a pas de doute on doute jamais on
ne doute jamais je voudrais finir avec
avec ceci parce que au vu des actualités
évidemment
de la menace nucléaire russe ça fait ça
fait réfléchir ça fait sens on célèbre
la catastrophe d'Hiroshima tout à fait
c'est il y a un calendrier réhélien qui
est calqué sur la catastrophe
d'Hiroshima donc aujourd'hui on est en
l'an 70 et quelques parce que ça fait
donc pendant ce stage il le stage
pourquoi il était fait au début du mois
d'août c'était au mois de début du mois
d'août qui a eu lieu le stage pourquoi
parce que
l'avant dernier jour du stage c'était
l'anniversaire c'était le nouvel an
le Nouvel An c'est l'anniversaire de la
catastrophe d'Hiroshima et pourquoi
Hiroshima parce que pour réel tout ce
qui est on est toujours au bord de la on
est au bord on est au bord de la
catastrophe tout le temps ça c'est
vraiment un caractéristique première des
mouvements sectaires c'est à dire que
ils ne sont pas millénaristes comme
comme peuvent l'être par exemple les
Témoins de Jéhovah qui appellent à la
fin du monde mais c'est tout comme c'est
à dire qu'ils disent que le monde va
bientôt être détruit par une catastrophe
nucléaire et évidemment la guerre en
Ukraine leur donne plutôt raison parce
que la situation se tend donc c'est vrai
que c'était c'est un discours qui le
Martel énormément le fait que on est au
bord du précipice et que seul les
raidiens peuvent sauver sauver le monde
merci beaucoup étienne Jacob alors je
remontre comme ça tout le monde est bien
au courant pour pouvoir vous lire vous
avez ici premier article c'est celui de
vendredi dernier donc là on parle de
votre arrivée comment vous vous avez
fait pour vous intégrer et rentrer dans
cette secte pas totalement dans la secte
mais en tout cas dans ce stage des
raeliens d'ici quoi allez vous m'avez
dit vers 17h 17h30 publication de la
deuxième partie donc là je vous lis
jeune sensoriel fin du monde annoncé et
du castration du castration de la
conscience l'infernal machine a peur du
mouvement Ryan donc là vous nous
expliquer finalement comment on se
laisse embarquer voilà comment on se
laisse embarquer avec évidemment
l'intervention du Grand Gourou Raël
voilà et puis vendredi prochain lorsque
vous aurez lu ces deux premières parties
ambassade extraterrestre ponction sur
salaire révolution sexuelle réel la
fructueuse multinationale sectaire vous
repartez vous allez en refaire
maintenant vous avez montré votre tête
ça va être difficile bah je pense que ce
qui est l'avantage c'est que les
mouvements sectaires souvent sont très
fermés sur eux et ne vont pas ça
s'informer via Le Figaro ou via des
médias donc c'est vrai que c'est ça me
permet de pouvoir continuer à en faire
bon je vous lance un autre défi la
Scientologie allez pourquoi pas ah ça
peut être une idée et puis lisez
jusqu'au bout parce que c'est très
intéressant à la fin de ce reportage je
ne dis rien je fais du teasing c'est un
peu moche j'avoue mais il y a des infos
rigolotes rester avec nous évidemment
sur le Figaro life parce que dans un
instant il y a le buzz TV évidemment et
puis il y a aussi la question du jour
avec avec Vincent roseron on parle de la
Russie faut-il accueillir ces russes qui
quitte la Russie en ce moment après
l'appel à la mobilisation partielle de
Vladimir Poutine et puis un peu plus
tard à 18h point de vue évidemment avec
un Emma Isaac la soirée vous restez avec
nous pour la passer sur le figarolive
nous on se retrouve lundi prochain merci
beaucoup bonne soirée